ladies and gentlemen let's get ready to
married
[Music]
you know check-in is great at different
moments during our time here we both
thought that tragic Mike over here was
our one true love and now he is marrying
or whatever Janet is I suppose her Raj
is a bit strange I'd like to read a poem
Janet my digital Queen Janet we can dare
to dream send nude pics of your heart to
me Jacksonville Jaguars room Jason when
I was rebooted and I lost all my
knowledge I was confused and disoriented
but you were always kind to me and
according to the central theme of 230
1600 songs movies poems and novels that
I research for these spells in the last
30 seconds that's what loves all about
does anybody here object to this
marriage overruled
Jason hmm do you want me to be your wife
yeah I want you to meet my husband toy
so by the power vested in me by me I now
pronounce us husband and wife we did it
can I kiss you or will I be electrocuted
only one way to find out go get a girl
I'm just going with it now
[Music]
it's funny I devastated when I found out
that he wasn't my soul mate but oh I
think I've dodged a bullet
he's a simple man I once watched him eat
electrical tape right off the roll he
thought it was a fruit by the foot that
had gone bad
thank you for being such a great friend
to me today course hot stuff I got your
back Eleanor hey I just wanted to see if
you talked to Cheney uh yeah I did I
mean you don't have to tell me what you
said I just wanted to see if you're okay
man you are a good person I swear if I
had known you and tani and GD on earth I
might have for real gotten into the good
place oh hey it's my three favorite
yogurt hey about what happened earlier
I've been kind of all over the place
today an hour ago I thought G on you was
my soul mate and the fact that that
kinda made sense means you and I could
never be meant for each other
Plus John use married to Janet now okay
what I do love you but I think more in a
best friend afterlife Savior kind of way
I'm not so much hot for teacher as I am
eternally grateful for semi cute
surprisingly ripped teacher JD I also
have to apologize when I found out that
Joni wasn't my soul mate I desperately
needed something to keep me afloat and
you were the nearest lifeboat as it were
and yes do have the sort of connection
that only two highly educated
sophisticates could have but it's not
true love true love is what Janice tangi
own you have yeah what oh we would love
to stay and chat but we need to find
Michael I don't know I think I figured
out the way for you to stay really I'll
come too
[Music]
you